Born into a poor peasant family in a foreign
land, no one had worse odds to become the
ruler of the Byzantine Empire than Basil.
Yet, through a combination of hard work, scheming,
murder and competence, Basil ascended to the
Byzantine throne and enjoyed 19 years of relatively
peaceful rule.
Authorities disagree over when and where Basil
was born.
Some place his birth year as 812 CE, while
others set it around 830 CE.
Ethnically Armenian, scholars also disagree
over whether he was born in Thrace, and then
carried off with his peasant parents as captives
of the Bulgarian khan Krum, or if he was born
in Macedonia after his parents were abducted.
Whatever the case, he lived for a time in
Macedonia, although Armenian was his first
language, and he is reported to have spoken
Greek (the language of Macedonia) with a noticeable
accent.
At some point, Basil, along with other captives,
escaped the Bulgarians and returned to their
homes in Thrace around 836.
Finding little opportunity there, he set off
to make his fortune in the big city.
His arrival in Constantinople has been transformed
by admiring historians into legend:
On a Sunday, near the hour of sunset, he reached
the Golden Gate, a poor unknown adventurer,
with staff and scrip, and he lay down to sleep
in the vestibule of the adjacent church of
St. Diomede.
During the night, Nicolas, who was in charge
of the church, was awakened by a mysterious
voice saying, “Arise and bring Basileus
into the sanctuary.”
He got up and looking out saw nothing but
a poor man asleep.
He lay down again, and the same thing was
repeated.
The third time, he was poked in the side by
a sword and the voice said, “Go out and
bring in the man you see lying outside the
gate.”
He obeyed, and on the morrow he took Basil
. . . and adopted him as a brother.[1]
Climbing through the Ranks
Regardless of the veracity of any supernatural
claims for Basil’s ascension, he was greatly
helped by the monk, Nicolas, who introduced
him to the doctor of a very rich and well
connected man, Theophilitzes.
Possessing extraordinary strength, Basil was
employed by the courtier (and relative of
the Empress Theodora) as a groom.
Together, they travelled to Patrae on the
Greek peninsula of Peloponnese.
There, Basil met (and impressed) the wealthy
Danelis.
Shortly thereafter, Basil fell ill (or faked
being sick) and was left behind by Theophilitzes.
When Basil recovered, Danelis became his patron
and made him a wealthy many by bestowing on
him slaves, gold and other items, ostensibly
in exchange for Basil taking her son under
his wing.
Nonetheless, Basil remained in Theophilitzes’
service and eventually reunited with him in
Constantinople.
While attending a wrestling match (Basil was
not originally one of the contestants), and
because of his enormous strength, he was invited
to take on that day’s champion; according
to one account: “Basil threw the Bulgarian,
squeezing him like a wisp of hay.
‘From that day the fame of Basil began to
spread through the city.'”[2]
The triumph was eventually reported to the
emperor Michael III.
Later, after Basil helped tame the emperor’s
intractable new horse that had resisted all
other efforts, Michael took Basil into his
own service as Hetaeriarch (captain of the
guard).
Shortly thereafter, Basil was appointed to
the post of High Chamberlain.
Totally obedient to Michael (or seemingly),
Basil divorced his wife at Michael’s command
and married Michael’s mistress (in name
only).
Many scholars believe that the children of
this marriage were actually Michael’s (including
Basil’s successor, Leo VI).
It is unclear if loyalty to Michael or personal
ambition was the driving force behind Basil’s
next move.
Basil had heard a rumor (or started one, depending
on your point of view) that the emperor’s
right hand man, the then second most-powerful
man in the Byzantine Empire, Caesar Bardas,
was planning to depose Michael.
Basil tried to warn the emperor, but Michael
did not believe him.
So Basil conspired with other ambitious young
men, including Symbatios, a young minister
and son-in-law to Caesar Bardas.
Together they were able to convince Michael
of Bardas’ treachery, and Bardas was eventually
murdered when Basil “and the other co-conspirators
rushed in and hewed him in pieces” right
in front of Michael.[3]
Grateful to be rid of the traitor, Michael,
who was officially childless, adopted Basil
as his son and promoted him to the rank of
Magister.
Then, mysteriously, on the Pentecost, May
26, 867 CE, Michael crowned Basil Basileus
and Augustus.
On the steps before the ambo in St. Sophia,
Michael addressed his subjects:
The Caesar Bardas plotted against me to slay
me, and for this reason induced me to leave
the city.
If I had not been informed of the plot by
Symbatios and Basil, I should not have been
alive now.
The Caesar died through his own guilt.
It is my will that Basil, the High Chamberlain,
since he is faithful to me and protects my
sovranty  and delivered me from my enemy
and has much affection for me, should be the
guardian and manager of my Empire and should
be proclaimed by all as Emperor.[4]
Friends Fall Out
Although Michael’s words were strong, the
real effect was that Basil was in charge of
the day-to-day operations of the empire, while
Michael retained his position as the true
emperor.
Hard to believe that didn’t end well.
Sure enough, the two had a falling out.
Michael began to think Basil was too big for
his britches, and he considered appointing
another to Basil’s place.
One drunken evening, Michael told Basil, “I
made you Emperor, and have I not the power
to create another Emperor if I will?”[5]
Having a talent for murder by this point,
Basil hatched a plot to kill Michael.
On September 24, 867 CE, Basil enticed Michael
to dinner; while Michael drank heavily, Basil
made an excuse to leave briefly.
He snuck into Michael’s chambers and jerry-rigged
the lock.
Returning later with eight buddies, Basil
and his co-conspirators hacked at Michael,
cutting off both of his hands before killing
him.
Basil’s position as emperor was now secure.
Basil’s Reign
During his 19 years as emperor, Basil kept
the ship of state on an even keel.
He oversaw the creation of a set of laws,
known as the Basilika, which governed Byzantium
until the fall of Constantinople in 1453.
He also extended Byzantium’s power by forming
alliances with European rulers and establishing
strongholds across the Adriatic and Mediterranean
Seas.
His greatest gift may have been his understanding
of human motivations.
He successfully navigated difficult court
politics and was able to keep its different
factions from ever uniting against him.
He also worked at maintaining a good image
with the common man by living piously, providing
orderly public services and maintaining relatively
light taxes.
Basil died on August 29, 886 CE.
He was succeeded by his son Leo VI the Wise.